whenever we see examples of ethical or
moral failure our knee-jerk reaction is
to say that was a bad person we like to
sort the world into good people who had
stable and enduring ly strong positive
characters and bad people who had weak
or frail characters and this belief that
somehow our behavior or our conduct is
largely shaped by who we are and our
true selves is I think one of the great
assumptions that we need to challenge if
we have to get a better handle on what
leads people to go astray
Lincoln was once asked what is a measure
of a person's character and he says you
know my experience is that most people
think that the true measure of a
person's character is how they respond
to adversity I have found Lincoln said
that the real test of a person's
character is to give them power and I
have been surprised how often I have
been disappointed by people's character
when they have been given power the
overconfidence that people have in their
own moral capacity is one of the things
that we have to be very careful about
most people think I am good I have the
proper moral compass I will never be led
astray that form of moral overconfidence
I think is sometimes what gets people
into trouble when they find themselves
in situations where the pressures are so
great that they are led astray thinking
hard about what it is about situations
that are more likely to tempt us and
what it is that are about situations
that are more likely to give us moral
courage is in my view one of the most
important things again that we need to
understand this is in no way intended to
excuse or provide or or not hold people
accountable when they commit a mistake I
just think that we always end up
focusing on the character the person as
if there was a bad seed that they always
were rather than recognizing that people
change that they find themselves in
circumstances where they can be frail
and where their own sense of moral
confidence can fail them so I am much
more inclined and this is one
things that we're trying to teach at her
business school it's true cases to allow
people to see that there are
circumstances in which if you have very
very high-powered incentives that are
tied to particular measures you may be
tempted at the margin to gain to achieve
those measures